you're gonna Gabi
kudamon Burhan with the Somali Kenyan
version at Steven Spielberg maybe but
the difference is that the Imams films
are not purely commercial the man has a
mission and it's called East Lee would
you get here if which is someone who is
actually Freddy from Somalia from fled
from al-shabaab who's the refugee but
they are trying actually to they're
doing business like hookahs choose China
small small facility nobody is sanitary
service people are busy telling a pseudo
criminal gang is like after all so we
are trying in one way to tell our
culture our positive side among thousand
east Leawood in 2001 fourteen years
after he came to Kenya for young Somalis
his creative platform is the only way
out of ethnic isolation before I reach
my home I get him list for many people
hey man I would like to be actor I would
like to be model of like to be think I
would have to pick that dance I am I
helping me out so immediately I should
sell I'll help you out as long as you
are talented
sometimes you okay you are passionate
for this I'm not sure I hope you it's
just right to mentor them you know to
motivate them and motivation is urgently
needed in the Somali community after the
terror attacks by al-shabaab on arrow
B's Westgate Mall
Iman and his colleague add an oz man
have seen discrimination on every level
after I was to get the rims commercial
was pretty bad people they don't think
of us as good people they just condemned
us you know it had sir you know when you
are like in a Matata and people start
looking at you like you know like a
suspect we don't deserve that al-shabaab
they don't stand for Somali
Eastley or little Mogadishu is dominated
by Somali businesses a quarter of
Nairobi's tax revenue is generated here
making it vital for Kenya's capital and
yet Somalis are culturally isolated
silence was it a man's project office
ethnic groups a chance to interact it
salud is playing a big role a very big
role because it has reduced crime in a
way because most of the guys who are
perpetrating heinous activities in the
community most most of them have joined
and also showcase their talent isla
woods films are shown in tiny cinema
halls in the neighborhood the challenge
however is that Iman and his team not
only face discrimination from Kenyans
they also struggle with accusations from
their own community so many people
actually trying to disseminate a lot of
propagandas telling us you guys you are
changing our youth you are getting a
beautiful garlic yeah but mooting
withstand you know fairly hoods they
want to ask yourself what do I do with
but I'm saying today if I die they are
someone like Iman who will take from it
and we hope this loot will work
generation is like Hollywood Iman's
project is funded by local businesses
and it turns out to be a very successful
one
you